there's not much left to fight for in
mario paul
but the sound of shelling is constant
no one flinches
after four weeks of this
they're used to it
this part of this port city is now
russian controlled and some people are
relieved about that
foreigner might be confused if if
the russians
they would say started this so why would
you have to be happy that the russians
are
is russian speaking ukraine was
oppressing us with their language we
learned it at first no problem but then
there was too much pressure then in 2013
the azov brigade came and it was chaos
the russians say this city has been
destroyed because the azov's a group
with neo-nazi sympathies won't surrender
the battalion is integrated into
ukraine's national guard but has some
autonomy
their presence here was one of vladimir
putin's justifications for launching
what he calls a special military
operation
ukraine says russia was just looking for
an excuse to invade
mario paul city council says there are
around 170 000 people still in the city
most have been without power or running
water or much food for a month
here you get an indication of the scale
of the need
there is here for humanitarian aid this
place has been under russian control now
for about a week this part of mariopol
and since then this has been turned into
an aid distribution center with food and
freshly cooked meals and some medical
assistance but all of these people from
here
they go back to what's left of their
homes
these people are caught in the middle of
one of the most strategically important
battles in ukraine
mario paul's capture would help russia
create a corridor to join crimea with
donetsk and lugansk and narrow ukraine's
access to the black sea
that's why neither side is giving up
so much cruelty under bombing shells
flying why was there a need to destroy
homes it's a military crime no one
should do it
both sides are guilty to bomb at night
to shoot kill
message boards are used to spread news
about who is safe who is missing
who has died mobile phone coverage is
erratic even if there is power
with russian control comes russian
administration the zed is everywhere the
hashtag reads we don't abandon our own
what began as an identification on
military vehicles in donbass has evolved
into russia's logo for this war
my neighbor's old she can't come i'll
share the food with her i'll share it
with everyone who lives on my street
there's so many people who are old who
just can't come her son is here to help
if russia takes full control of mariopol
it'll be the first major ukrainian city
to fall a morale boost to one side a
psychological blow to the other
too much is at stake
for there to be any let up in the
shelling
bernard smith al jazeera mario paul
to moscow now and russia's president
vladimir putin is threatening to end gas
contracts if countries do not start
paying in rubles
i signed an order that establishes the
rule of trade with natural gas with the
so-called hostile states where offering
a clear system that they have to open
accounts in rubles and payments have to
be made through these accounts from the
1st of april if they don't we will
consider it an unfulfillment of contract
nobody sells us anything for free and we
will not do charity so their existing
contracts will be suspended when they
use them as weapons
mahabharata is in the russian capital
foreign session this seems like quite a
big move from the russian president
it is indeed it is a retaliation against
what the russians
have been describing as an economic war
launched against them by the west they
say that the sanctions that were imposed
on russia the freezes of the assets and
the bans on the russian natural gas
exports were meant to further undermine
russia and put more pressure on the
russian government now they are
retaliating so in a tit-for-tat the
russians started a week ago when
president vladimir putin ordered the
central bank to work out new mechanisms
with all the supplies of the russian
natural gas to unfriendly countries so
when he says unfriendly countries he's
talking about the us eu uk and other
countries will have to be now paid in
the local currency in the ruble and they
say this is a legitimate right for the
russians because they are facing those
uh
wide range of sanctions now for those
countries the unfriendly countries that
they have to open up uh
accounts in russian banks starting from
tomorrow
this is where the new rule rules come
into the place to be able to see those
supplies continuing otherwise the
contracts will be
stopped and it's quite interesting to
see that the russian president vladimir
putin is adamant about the need to move
forward with that retaliationary
retaliatory measure because
he understands that europe in particular
uh uh relies on uh the 40
of its uh energy needs come from russia
just about a week ago when vladimir
putin ordered the bank to the central
bank to work out those measures we saw
the energy prices spike to something
like 30 percent in europe and this
explains why in his speech he was
talking about warning against potential
repercussions of his decision on the
international market and also because of
the sanctions he says we are likely to
see food crisis we are likely to see a
migration
crisis following in europe we are likely
to see
unemployment uh spiking in europe and
the the economic drive in europe will
definitely
face a major setback because it's coming
back against the backdrop of a need to
recover from the crunch it suffered
during uh uh during uh kovid 19 uh
pandemic so quite obvious that the the
russians are moving forward to use uh
energy as an asset in
in this confrontation with the west in
particular and they say you know what
united foreign you are making us you
know pay a price for the military
campaign in ukraine therefore you will
have also to
bear the brunt of what happens uh next i
think the russians are trying also to
put more pressure on the uh on the west
particularly on the eu uh with this uh
new rules about uh
about paying in ruble there could be
another motive by the russians which is
basically if you remember came at the
beginning of the crisis we saw the ruble
the local currency plunge dramatically
uh uh following the following the
sanctions that were imposed on russia
and by this move now vladimir putin is
building trust on the
on the local currency is pushing more
countries now to pay in the local
currency and this is likely to further
just prop up
the ruble which has gained significantly
in value compared to the dollar over the
last few days all right hashimoto there
in moscow thank you